Ein Waschbär, eine Eule und
ein Schneemann im Frühling:
Insgesamt 24 mit Narzissen
geschmückte Figuren schwimmen
über den Altaussee in Österreich. Es
ist der Höhepunkt des Jahres
für die Region und das größte
Blumenfest Mitteleuropas.
Rund 20.000 Besucher bestaunen
jährlich dieses Spektakel.
So ein Festival habe ich noch nie
in meinem Leben gesehen.
In meinem Land Sri Lanka gibt es
solche Blumenfeste nicht.
Ich bin wirklich beeindruckt.
Es ist für mich das erste Mal.
Ich bin begeistert, dass die Leute
so sich bemühen und für uns alle …
Wir sind dankbar, dass alle
zusammengekommen [sind].
Ja, ich finde, dass dann so die Tiere
verkleidet [sind]
mit so [einer] Lederhose oder so
traditioneller Tracht [und] Kleidungen,
das fand ich sehr, sehr lustig
und sehr schön.
Für eine Figur werden mehrere
Zehntausend Narzissen gebraucht.
Erst am Nachmittag vor dem großen
Blumenkorso beginnen die Teilnehmer damit,
die Blüten zu stecken. Bis in die
Morgenstunden kann es dauern,
bis eine Skulptur fertig ist.
Helga König hat Erfahrung damit.
Seit rund 30 Jahren macht sie
beim Narzissenfest mit.
Für sie eignet sich die Narzisse
perfekt zum Stecken.
Weil sie keine Blätter hat, einen ganz
glatten Stiel [hat] und der Stiel
schwerer ist als wie die Blüte.
Und dadurch hängt sie schön drinnen.
Also wenn man andere Blüten nimmt,
dann sieht man’s immer …
Dann muss der Stil sehr lang sein, dass
das drinnen im Gitter hängen bleibt.
Also, das ist schwierig sonst
mit einer anderen Blüte.
Die Region Ausseerland-Salzkammergut
verwandelt sich im Frühling
in ein duftendes Blumenmeer. Die weiße
Stern-Narzisse blüht hier
von Mitte Mai bis Mitte Juni.
Für die Figuren werden die Narzissen
von Hand gepflückt. Das Pflücken schadet
den Pflanzen nicht. Im Gegenteil:
So bleibt der Blume mehr Kraft zur
Fortpflanzung für das nächste Jahr.
Damit die Blüten frisch bleiben, müssen
die Teilnehmer auf einiges achten.
Na, bei dem Pflücken ist einmal ganz
wichtig, dass man sie maximal
drei Tage davor pflückt, kühl lagert,
dass die Blüten nicht nass werden,
weil dann werden sie braun, und dann halt,
dass man sie relativ schnell verarbeitet.
Hochbetrieb bei den Vorbereitungen:
Viele Freiwillige helfen beim Stecken mit.
Dabei gilt die Regel: Immer drei bis vier
Narzissenblüten werden zu einem Bund
zusammengenommen und in ein Loch
gesteckt. So haben sie mehr Halt.
Elisabeth Sorschak ist für das Fest
aus der Nähe von Wien angereist.
Für die Narzissenliebhaberin geht damit
ein Kindheitstraum in Erfüllung.
Wir haben dann heute schon in der
Früh auf der Alm gepflückt.
Es war auch sehr schwierig.
Wir haben nasse Schuhe gehabt und so.
Und heute haben wir sie dann hergebracht,
und die haben sich gefreut,
obwohl die Blumen ja gar nicht mehr
so perfekt waren. Aber jetzt haben
wir gesteckt, das ist eine tolle Erfahrung,
ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl.
Normalerweise müssen die Figuren aus
mindestens 70 Prozent Narzissen bestehen.
Dieses Jahr wurde die Regelung wegen
einer schlechten Narzissenernte gelockert.
Deshalb dürfen auch andere Blüten wie
Margeriten oder auch Naturmaterialien
wie Moos verwendet werden.
Die Teilnehmer des Stadtkorsos
in Bad Aussee machen das Beste daraus.
Hier werden alle Figuren präsentiert.
Egal ob Tier- oder Fantasiefigur:
Der Kreativität sind keine Grenzen gesetzt.
Wichtig ist es, das Publikum und eine
20-köpfige Jury zu überzeugen.
Es gibt einen Bewertungskatalog,
der sieben Punkte umfasst.
Das ist von der Dichtheit der Narzissen
begonnen über den Gesamteindruck,
über die Größe. Das sind sieben
verschiedene Punkte, und da kann man
schon abwägen, in welche Richtung es
von der Platzierung ungefähr geht.
Am Ende gewinnen die Eule, der Waschbär
und der Clown erste Preise im Rennen
um die schönste Narzissenfigur. Runde
Formen sind bei der Bewertung im Vorteil,
da sie schwieriger zu stecken sind.
Das allein reicht aber nicht für den Sieg.
Meines Beiseins kommt es darauf an,
dass es was Lustiges ist,
was Fröhliches ist, dass [es] gut
rüberkommt das Ganze eigentlich.
Die Gewinnerin der Herzen ist und bleibt
die Narzisse und ihre Heimat:
die Berg- und Seenlandschaft
des Salzkammerguts.